good morning everybody before we open
our public hearing for Senate Bill 504
if you would please uh join me in the
Pledge of Allegiance this
morning I am going to open the public
hearing for Senate Bill
504 and recognize the prime sponsor to
introduce his
legislation morning Mr
President good morning members of the
committee so pleased to be here for the
record Jeb Bradley Senate District
three and sponsor of Senate Bill 504 I
was asked to sponsor this bill by the
governor um based
on issues in the North country in terms
of um immigration and policy that we
have along our um northern border so
currently right now um if you are a land
owner and you post your land and um you
lose the extra 20% discount and there
are um mechanisms allowed for posting um
but it has to be done in such a way that
um would comply with the law so that
people are still El eligible for current
use so if you look at the bill um it's
the new language is starting on line six
it says an owner of open space land may
post a no trespass sign except for
skiing snowmobile snowshoeing fishing
hunting hiking or nature observation
signs a prohibit restrict access um to
or use of such space land for any other
purpose so this will allow um land
owners in current use to be able to post
their land against
trespassing um except for those
um activities outlined here so it's very
specific um and I worked with a couple
of folks that are here this morning I'm
representing the timber owners and other
folks that are really uh concerned about
current use to do this in the correct
way so that
um there could be posting of land now
the purpose for the bill and the reason
that uh the governor asked me to
introduce it is
the immigration issues and the northern
border um security and people that are
illegal in this country crossing the
border illegally and our law enforcement
can do uh nothing about that um I don't
need to go into all of the issues
surrounding illegal immigration in the
United States we see it on the news
every night but suffice it to say the
nor northern border is becoming more um
insecure as people realize that it's
relatively easy to cross um there have
been many Statistics over the Swanton
sector um over the last year or so that
highlight the large increase
percentage-wise in the number of people
crossing the northern border um our
northern border along the 50 plus miles
is um very rural very remote and very
hard um
for Customs and Border Patrol agents
that have been um the numbers have been
reduced in order to send some of these
folks to the southern border so it is
much more insecure so the purpose of the
bill is to allow local law enforcement
um to have the ability to arrest for
trespass under state law um this does
not create a federal crime um any kind
of federal issues would have to be done
through the border patrol but it would
allow local law enforcement to arrest
for trespassing and better coordinate
with um Customs and Border Patrol so I'm
happy to try to answer any
questions thank you Senator Senator um
we've heard some push back considering
statistics saying that you know the
numbers aren't really that high to
justify this in your opinion does it
does it matter what the statistics are
if the do wide open the I think there
reasons why the numbers are not that
high resources have been taken away from
the northern border and it's very remote
so by the time um officers get to an
area where there might be you know
reported incidents is that people are
gone and I've talked to folks that live
you know on the northern border farmer
up there in particular Keith Robinson um
who supplied a letter to the Senate and
I'm happy to get it to you um outlined
exactly that problem he has seen people
um crossing the border illegally on his
property calls the appropriate
authorities by the time they get there
they're long gone so the statistics that
you know you are hearing you have to
take that into account less resources
Federal resources on the border and the
remoteness of it and and the fact that
by the time um CBP actually gets to the
reported incident the folks are gone
because of the remoteness so why
wouldn't we want to empower local law
enforcement to um be able to work with
CBP to take action I mean it's not just
drugs the northern border has become
increasingly less secure
for people on the terrorist watch list
crossing the border um this this is a
problem it's not just the 50 or so miles
in New Hampshire it is the
entire you know several thousand mile
northern border that is problematic but
we can only do what we can do in New
Hampshire this is a small step um on top
of the provision that we placed into the
budget last year the $1.4 million to
pay for local law enforcement to step up
enforcement
issues further questions representative
Pratt good morning uh we presently the
fishing game I guess has no trespassing
signs that they make available will they
still will they be able to make signs
that say all this on
it so I think the way this um reads
that you would have to post according to
what the current use statute says so you
would have to if you wanted to take the
additional discount you would have to
say no trespass except for those six um
items skiing snowshoeing fishing hunting
hiking or nature observation that's what
the current use law now allows so you
have to delineate that posting when I
originally sponsored the bill um it just
said you prop post no trespassing that's
where the Timberland owners and and some
other folks who are here in the room um
came and and worked with the Attorney
General's office on this specific
language to allow it to be in
conformance with um the current use
statute thank
you represent
Newman thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question um I'm I'm reading the bill and
I have some conf confusion because it
appears that there was some problem with
the way trespassing was posted before
that took away the the benefits you got
with current
use and in the bill I see that the
trespassing signs need to be this spe
specific language to keep that benefit
is that right that is correct those
activities if you have your land in Cur
use and you get the discount for current
use plus the additional
discount if you're going to remain in
current use you have to allow those
activities so unless you are partaking
of those activities then that's when you
would be
trespassing
followup so my followup if it's all just
about changing the trespassing for
property in New Hampshire I hear all of
the other discussion about the board
coordination with the border the
problems with the Border all of those
kind of things and I'm wondering where
is it in this
bill that addresses that and has changed
anything in reference between the law as
it current used to exist as it exists
now and as this changes it so you get
the coordination and how it's going to
help with the Border okay so what this
bill would do is allow for local law
enforcement to be able to interdict
somebody trespassing except for those
delineated activities so if somebody is
walking across the border illegally
they're not um skiing or snowshoeing or
fishing hunting hiking okay so by virtue
of
creating the opportunity for PE for law
enforcement to arrest somebody who is
crossing the border illegally
trespassing but still allowing the
property owners who have their property
in current
use um most of which is along the
northern border of the private property
on the border that is in current use
that is what creates the opportunity for
federal I mean for state law enforcement
to um be able to utiliz trespassing
laws
quick
followup so to be arrested for
trespassing they would have to be on
land that is posted correctly that's
correct other places there's no
difference between the border and if
they're not trespassing it doesn't help
border if land were not in current use
you could post just a no trespassing
sign a current use to get the additional
discount you would have to post in this
fashion thank
you thank you Mr chair um how is a law
enforcement officer going to determine
whether someone is hiking or whether
they're crossing the border uh they
would
obviously talk to people see what they
were doing and you know obviously if you
are skiing you have skis on if you're
snowshoeing you have snowshoes on
fishing you have fishing
parapan Alia hunting same thing I think
it becomes pretty
obvious I would suggest that hiking
would be part of a a the criminal
investigation where they would say you
know where where you from where you
heading um do do you have the perel for
hiking you got or are you just I mean
that would be a probable cause issue
that'll end up probably in the court um
representative
Muse thank you for taking my question
given the remoteness of the area and the
100 fot posting requirement uh and the
fact that quite a bit of land up there
isn't already current use one of the
things I'm wondering is just how much
additional protection uh this is going
to provide so has anybody actually
looked at how many people may
actually uh take up an offer like this
uh and what level of impact would it
actually have on the situation
well I think every little bit
helps um obviously there's a lot of
public land along the border but there
is um private land in current use I
spoken to you know a farmer who owns um
I I think he said a 230 Acre Farm on the
border his name is Keith Robinson who
has seen people crossing the border
illegally and by the time he has um you
know phoned it into authorities and
given the remoteness of the area um by
the time authorities arrive they're long
gone so as I said I think any little bit
helps see you no further questions uh
thank you Mr President for your time and
that'll be
up who's next thank you
yeah so anyone else wishing to testify
on this bill who hasn't testified on
this bill seeing N I hear by Clos public
hearing okay next one is up
10:30
e
with that I'm opening the um public
hearing on Senate Bill 564 and I invite
the sponsor to introduce the
bill oh
e
go ahead good morning chairman Roy
morning Senator and good morning
honorable members my name is Senator
Deborah alel I represent Senate District
24 which includes the towns of exor
Greenland Hampton Hampton Falls
Northampton rye and
stratom Senate Bill 564 adds language to
the definition of the term child in RSA
649 A2 and would read child means any
person under the age of 18 years or
something which is portrayed to be a
person under the age of 18 and therefore
indistinguishable from a
child the scourge of people abusing
children in the production of child sex
abuse imagery exploiting those children
for life by selling and exchanging those
images and videos on the internet and in
the black market exchanges can be
addressed by this
legislature we are very fortunate to in
New Hampshire to have the internet
crimes against children task force
investigating these kinds of
crimes it has been my honor and pleasure
to work with the internet crimes against
children task force uh from my previous
work in advocacy for abused children and
then subsequently in my work here as a
member of the house and now in the
Senate um it is
unfortunate that we need them but what
they do is
invaluable the uh Lieutenant Eric
Kinsman could not be here today because
is my understanding that the internet
crimes against children task force is
conducting a number of raids
today um we are very very fortunate to
have Holly Ray here from the from the
task force and I believe she'll be
testifying a little bit
later we what we can do to assist them
in fiing out these perpetrators of
violence against children is to
acknowledge the rapid changes in
software and the way that they are being
used in criminal Enterprise I have a
attached my testimony says I have
attached two articles that is true you
have two articles but you also have an
opinion piece um from uh Pitzer
prizewinning author Nicholas Kristoff
about this
Scourge
um these articles uh explain the issues
associated with the rapid evolution of
child sex abuse imagery in the
artificial intelligence space New
Hampshire can't wait for the artificial
intelligence world to police itself and
if practice is precedent they won't
Senate Bill 564 is an important change
in the law and I hope you will recommend
it ought to pass as quickly as possible
thank you for your time and attention
and I am open to any
questions thank you Senator um it's my
understanding that the the ACLU has
taking a negative position on this bill
and they're they're claim claiming the
Free Speech exception based on a Case
called Ashcraft that dealt with
something like this but not in my
opinion like this because they never the
Ashcraft Court didn't have to contend
with the AI technology that exists now
and I I would submit that they may have
a different opinion um have you had a
chance to discuss this at all with them
or um no I have not and this is the
first I'm hearing that the ACLU is in
are you saying oppos or just raising
questions pretty pretty clear opposition
okay um well I will I will share with
the committee that it has been my
experience in working um for laws that
protect criminal
victims uh that the ACLU has not
necessarily been a partner in protecting
the rights of the people who have been
harmed by criminals in so much as
protecting the rights of the criminals
so um I you can take that for what you
will but I I have yet to have a criminal
victim's Justice bill that they have
embraced so there you are I I did um I I
raised their concerns with the Attorney
General's office and they seem to be
also of the opinion that the Reliance on
that older case um that Court did not
have ai in front of them it wasn't even
existing at that point which makes a big
difference so thank you chairman Roy I
appreciate that you brought that up with
them with the Attorney General's office
because AI um in the use
of of
um abusing young children and older
teens um has
proliferated absolutely proliferated and
created an entire New Market where real
faces of real children from our state
are superimposed on sexually graphic and
horrific horrific sexual crimes and once
something's out there you can't unring
the bell and we want to at least provide
a space um for law enforcement to be
able to act and um for the law to make
space for those
victims thank you questions for Senator
representative seig and then
representative PR thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question I just
wondered if you had seen the story in
Monday's New York Times um entitled teen
girls confront an epidemic of deep fake
nudes at schools that addressed um it's
a reporter who did an investigative
piece that started with a case in New
Jersey that um revealed similar issues
to what you're showing but also talked
about the struggles because they don't
have the laws in place yet to address it
um yeah actually one of the articles
that you have addresses um originally
the New Jersey problem and what the
struggles are in states that for where
victims are coming forward and law
enforcement has nothing there's no way
to charge this because it AI is a new
it's a whole new
chapter and unfortunately we're late
we're late we have to catch up before um
more people are sucked into this
representative Pratt hello hi thanks for
taking my question my pleasure um I
agree with everything you said and uh I
like the changes in the first paragraph
here but I have questions about page two
line 11 okay um doesn't allowing
drawings cartoons sculptures and
paintings feed this
problem
basically it says they're going to
exempt anything in those
areas
um
so I agree with you um are you looking
at the definition exceptions on 13 and
14 yeah 11 12 13 14 yes yeah
um so indistinguishable is the new
definition which we do want for IND
distinguishable indistinguishable
meaning virtually indistinguishable that
if I saw your face in one of these
videos um the depiction would be such
that any person here viewing it would
conclude that the depiction is actually
of you even if it wasn't but an ordinary
person could would say oh that's
representative Pratt and that is a harm
to you um
in order to um address some concerns
that were coming out of other groups the
definition carved out drawings cartoons
sculptures and
paintings depicting minors or adults as
that fell into some First Amendment and
satirical
boundaries thank you I don't love it but
it's where we are yeah I would love if
you would love of this and sta passing
it and we can both not love that part
and maybe do something about it later
that I follow up please yeah I just I do
believe there is a a Supreme Court case
that deals with cartoons and things of
that nature which would have to be
overturned for us to be able to do this
go ahead fall they fall into satire yeah
and and political commentary so it's
it's a rocky road there so that there's
the carve out that's the piece I see
being used in local libraries as a uh is
a uh way out of taking something out
that shouldn't be in the
library it's a cartoon or it's a
artwork okay thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you Senator
thank you very much thank you honorable
members chair calls Holly
Ray
representative Sor can you print that
Times article for our
uh yeah we'll talk about it
after chairman uh honorable members of
this committee thank you for uh having
me here to speak my name is Holly Ray I
am currently a sergeant with the State
Police Special investigation unit um one
of our primary duties of our unit is
investigating child exploitation
offenses um and other cyber related
crimes the New Hampshire State Police is
a member of the New Hampshire is an
affiliate member of the New Hampshire
internet crimes against children's task
force um also referred to commonly as
the
iak one of our unit's primary
responsibilities is conducting iak
investigations um we also do examine
digital evidence that is seized during
the execution of search warrants for The
Possession and distribution of child
sexual abuse imagery since RSA
6492 uh a colon 2 was enacted technology
has evolved there are now numerous
software programs available that can
generate realistic images or videos that
are virtually indistinguishable from a
real person artificial intelligence can
generate images and videos of people
that are again indistinguishable from an
actual person this includes child
Predators utilizing AI to create new
images and videos of children in sexual
positions or per Performing sexually
explicit acts iak investigators Nation
Nationwide are also finding AI tools are
increasingly being promoted on child
predator
forums as ways to create un uncensored
sexual depictions of children in my
experience reviewing C reviewing seized
digital evidence I've come across these
such images some of which have included
minors engaging in sexually explicit
conduct making the possession of this
type of material illegal will also allow
law enforcement the ability to take
enforcement Action Against Child
Predators it could also further prevent
the exploitation of Children online
unfortunately the internet has become a
place child Predators L lure groom
exchange child sexual abuse abuse
material transfer it that was never
previously possible as technology
evolves it's imperative that the law
keeps up in order to protect the most
vulnerable members of our
society that is all I have for everyone
I appreciate the time and I'm happy to
take any
questions thank you Sergeant um so
basically what what can happen now as my
understanding is someone who interacts
with children be it a coach a mentor
whatever could take a picture of a minor
a female Minor's face or male and have
that program superimpose it into an
existing pornography movie whereas the
person in the pornography movie is for
all intents and purposes that child is
that correct yes essentially sir okay
and based on your training and
experience when uh a predator like this
isn't that really the first step before
they start moving on to actually
contacting and touching and or abducting
and hurting that child yes there has
been a uh a high correlation in the I's
experience between people that view
child sexual abuse imagery and that are
touch
offenders thank you further questions
represent wheeler thank you Mr chairman
this will be a quick question thank you
Sergeant for taking my question I just
want to know how prolific a problem this
is in New Hampshire and if there are
more resources that are that should be
allocated to a program like gak to make
sure that we can deal with this this is
horrific in my opinion um thank you for
your question sir
um I think the best I think the iak task
force may have a better idea of in
general what resources would really help
the task force itself um however I can
say that um unfortunately child The
Possession distribution and child sexual
abuse imagery material crimes um are a
huge issue in our state um I think we
have great laws in place to help law
enforcement combat it um and this
addition would be extremely beneficial
to that fight against crimes against
children further questions
representative
seig thank you and thank you for taking
my question um to follow up on chairman
Roy's question about um people using
this so if someone were to make one of
these deep fake type of things for a
minor um are are people using it to do
things like essentially blackmail them
into sending real imagery potentially or
to like in addition to trying to groom
them uh for actual physical abuse um I'm
not phrasing my question well I'm sorry
but are people using this for the
purposes of sort of you know kids are
Gable often I as a parent of teenager um
you know I can see how this can lead to
that but is that one of the methods that
they're using is to I I'm not familiar
with a specific case ma'am and thank you
for your question um
however the idea of something such as
revenge porn or um a child who does
happen to send a a nude selfie um I have
dealt with and we do have a number of
cases that do involve that I just don't
know one um in my experience yet of one
that was technically AI generated um
however the the uh the blackmail
situation is a definite offense and like
you said kids are unfortunately very
vulnerable especially in the social
media World um and one thing predators
do do is they are able to convince them
to send some sort of sexually explicit
photo of themselves and then in
turn essentially blackmail them either
into sending additional photos to that
Predator I can only assume that that
will be a problem in the AI world as
well thank you for your
question Sergeant I also it occurs to me
that um not only Predators this is
probably going to develop into um other
teenagers getting access to this and
creating videos of young women and
posting them and we could end up with
suicides and things of that nature based
on would you agree that that's a
possibility yes sir I I would I would um
strongly agree that that is a
possibility um and again for lack of
term I think the most common term for it
is revenge porn and we are we are seeing
that as a um unfortunate um part of AI
technology um I'm sure a few of you have
maybe read instances of celebrities um
deep fakes of celebrities going on and
basically imposed in pornographic videos
um and to be quite Frank most of the
most of the things I read in the news do
pertain to AI being utilized in
pornographic material thank you
representative Pratt thank you for
taking my question um it's pretty much
the same one I before page two line 13
and 14 right now the irsa does not
exempt drawings cartoons sculptures and
paintings but that line there does
paintings that depict a minor or an
adult so does that weaken this bill this
uh this
RSA um because it it um because it
excludes the drawings cartoons sir yes
cartoons drawings sculptures
it is not Exempted in the previous right
now in the
RSA I I think and to expand on what the
senator was saying before me um the
problem with the cartoons drawings and
sculptures and paintings is is the term
indistinguishable um it's it's very
important in when we are reviewing
digital evidence and when we do find
evidence of child sexual abuse material
it's it's very important for me to be
able to say that that is a child um and
one of the ways I do look for are
certain
characteristics I think it would be very
hard for me to note those
characteristics and to be able to report
on those characteristics when it's a
drawing or cartoon or
sculpture I believe that might be the
the difficulty with that definition sir
just f one for
up would we be better off just to leave
that line out line 13 through
uh I'm
not I guess I'm not sure I feel like I
leave that up to you folks and your and
uh you have a little more um uh
experience with this than I do so thank
you thank you
sir represent
Reed I
pass anyone else see you no further
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you everyone for your time I
appreciate it any is anyone else wishing
to testify in this bill who has not done
so seeing no one I here by close the
executive S I mean excuse me the public
hearing we reconvene at 1:00 is that
right
yeah
e
good afternoon
this is the uh criminal justice
committee executive session and welcome
to it um we're going to start with do
you have the the listed today I you I
know but is this in
order we're going to start
with Senate Bill
248 relative to bail for a
defendant we um we have all agreed
that the work we did as a committee this
summer on um a comprehensive bail
package that was sent to the uh finance
committee and it's my understanding it's
come out of there with a positive
recommendation so we're going to hold on
to um any Senate bail bills um in
recognition of the work that we did that
address is already addressed in all the
bails they sent us so with that in mind
I am recessing Senate Bill 248 to a
later date to be detered
termin next up Senate
Bill
418 this is a bill with uh relative to
refusal consent to testing undetermined
alcohol concentration penalties um I
have made some inquiries into the state
police that I'm waiting for information
on and we're not prepared to um exact
that at this time so I am going to um
recess that one as well 418 is recessed
until next
Friday
Senate Bill
425 Senate Bill 425 again uh another
bail bill that addresses Comm bail
commissioner fees the bill that just
came out of finance that we all worked
on last summer um actually raised the
commissioner fees an additional $10 to
what we raised it and it's now at $60 so
um this bill is also going to go on hold
and is recessed to next Friday as
well the next bill is Senate Bill
460 relative to unmanned aircraft
systems and I recognize representative
Newman to make a bell I make a
motion thank you Mr
Speaker oh
yeah God I get these two places mixed up
I call him the chairman and you the
speaker I don't know what's going on
with
that a
compliment okay
I make a motion that this bill ought to
pass with Amendment and I have the
amendments in my hand I'll second no
okay so first we need to introduce the
amendment second yeah well I'm just
saying he's making a motion to introduce
the amendment I will make a motion
for
Amendment see 2024 14400 H and seconded
by representative rhods
e
um you can stay up here to you don't
have to sit over there to introduce your
Amendment yeah it's coming around if you
haven't got it
yet representative Muse is holding on to
them representative um Newman would you
like to speak to your
motion
I'll speak to my
motion um this amendment replaces the
entire Bill there there were um a few
minor Provisions that um didn't keep the
copy that they gave me to see the
provisions but it has a new paragraph
that is associated with another
appropriate
RSA and so they corrected the language
and the language has been corrected and
uh I commend like I said ought to pass
with Amendment thank you representative
RS would you like to speak to your
second the only thing I would add Mr
chair is I I do remember last I think it
was last week when we heard this bill um
we formed that quick little subcommittee
and representative Newman fixed whatever
whatever the concern was I'm trying to
find the bill myself in like five
minutes and then you we were able to
just kind of dis dissolve the
subcommittee because it wasn't really
necessary if that's that's pretty much
how I right that that's exactly what
happened and the appropriate language is
in there and I was getting ready to
compare the amendment to the bill as as
submitted and unfortunately we went
through though I've never seen us go
through three bills so fast so anyway um
that's where it stands if I could
inquire and the stakeholders are happy
with this
amendment believe some of them here and
they might be able to help me out of
what actually changed in it yeah if if
you wouldn't mind um just telling us
that you're happy with the changes and
understand that what we've
done good afternoon Trisha Lambert I'm
the administrator for the Bureau of
Aeronautics for the New Hampshire
Department of Transportation so the two
sections that I was concerned with um
were the first um of which they did put
that back in and make the appropriate
changes and sorry I didn't get all the
way to the other end um and then the
second piece which is at the end which
is new paragraph that crosses over to 4
RSA 422 29 um appears to be
correct in um representative Newman was
the was the state police part of this
conversation on this
amendment because they were the ones no
I don't know I know yes they as a matter
of fact there was the police office
standing there and I did show it to him
and we they were good we straightened it
up and he had no objections great thank
you
okay any further
discussion just good to um see no
further discussion um I ask the clerk to
call the role on the adoption of
amendment number
140 motion is to adopt Vice chair roads
yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec representative PR
yes representative jren or
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tenar yes representative
Harry Gite yes representative Muse yes
representative Balden yes representative
Schultz yes representative gerana yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative sake yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy ch ch 190 19
190 the motion is um of to adopt the
amendment is carried um would anyone
like to make another motion
representative Newman like to make the
motion to a to pass as
amended motion made and seconded by
representative rhods any further
discussion
necessary seeing none I'll ask the cour
to call the role the motion of floor is
asked ought to pass with
Amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec yes representative PR yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tenar yes representative
Harry goth yes representative Muse yes
representative Balon yes representative
Schultz yes representative gerana yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative selig yes representative
wheeler chairman Roy Geralds 190 190
motion carries uh to pass any objection
to consent seeing none of going
consent executive session is
closed with that I will open the
executive session on House Bill hold on
second 504 this is the um Bill we heard
this
morning um the language of this bill I
think um we discussed with some of the
spons and we think that we can tweak it
a little bit and so we're going to
recess this one to next Friday as
well next um executive session I open
house bill
564 that's the bill we heard this
morning relative to the AI and child um
pornography um representative gather
harri gther would you like to make a
motion on this
one I motion are to pass seconded motion
made and seconded by representative
Murray would you like to speak to your
motion representative yes um the fact
that AI has really gone crazy throughout
the United States and in New Hampshire
as well I think this is a great
protection for our young
folks thank you would you like to speak
to your second representative
maray um I am all set thank you I would
just add that I I think this is a uh a
good bill and a good first step um it
may end up it may end up testing the the
legal field um of the existing jurist
Prudence with the Ashcraft case which as
I said before did not address AI so it'
be interesting to see where this goes
but I think it's a good step towards
protecting our children so I would also
urge the members to support the a to
pass motion um any further
discussion representative uh
Muse one thing that I wanted to bring up
is we do understand um the difference uh
between this bill and some of the other
things that we passed um earlier in the
session we we passed a similar Bill uh
that would essentially make the uh the
non-consensual use of uh pornographic
sexualized imagery um a crime in New
Hampshire we're in effect we're adding
it to our revenge Port porn Statute in
this particular case this particular
Bill does not require a particular
individual uh to be harmed uh as I read
the bill what it could do uh is
essentially make it possible for
somebody who is uh uh possessing and
circulating uh an a composite image of a
child to be
prosecuted I feel um based on what I've
heard about the market for pornography
and about how
the essentially
what
what you know the the dilemma I think
faced you know by our our law
enforcement uh folks I I feel that the
that composite images today are are so
realistic that um many of them even with
the technology we have available today
they're virtually indistinguishable from
from that of a real child and and what
what this particular Market does what
what these images do is they create a
market for more images so whether it's a
mar whether it's an image of a real
child or whether it's a very realistic
composite image of of a child that never
existed essentially we're talking about
the same thing and we're also talking
about the fact that the very fact that a
market for this type of material exists
means that if we allow that market to
continue to exist real children are
going to be harmed so I I think it's
important that we pass this
Bill thank you further discussion
representative sik thank you very much I
I just would like to say as the parent
of teenagers and knowing how incredibly
impressionable and how easily persuaded
they are by things that may or may not
be accurate um and and the risk for them
to be subjected to um people using
images that they've created artificially
for blackmail or sex tortion
um that it's really crucial to pass
legislation like this for the sake of
all of our
kids thank you further discussion
representative
scitec representative C you said they're
very persuadable I can't persuade them
to do homework I don't know how you do
it
but see you no further did you have some
see no further discussion I ask the
clerk to call the rooll the motion to
floor is out to pass Vice chair roads
yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative
pu yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harry goth yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Schultz yes
representative gerana yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes yes
representative selig yes representative
wheeler chairman Roy chair votes yes 190
by vote of 19 to Z the motion passes any
objection to consent see none go on
consent I hereby close the executive
session and with that we have concluded
our business until uh next Wednesday um
see you all tomorrow at
the
session if anybody is curious I did find
the uh the amendment in the Bill for the
air aircraft the the changes was for the
first offense it will be a violation and
for the second and subsequent offenses
it will be a misdemeanor where the first
bill was straight up
misdemeanor
e
for